foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that wasn't nice nothing but bad news
for the Iowa stallions what an idiot
Mr Markovich I will offer you community
service coaching adults with
intellectual disabilities
no boo-boo words
hey fellas we're going to do a simple
ball handling exercise my girlfriend
loves this
you don't have to turn them into the
Lakers they just need to feel like a
team
uh we're gonna need some help you're
getting a player off the injured list
welcome to the team cosentina what's
with the boogie board you do you I do me
okay where do you got this guy he just
showed up one day
this is my sister Alex you wanna do a
couple karaoke with us
again now you gotta keep me down
you know the game better than anybody
you got a defense over here you got to
learn to build relationships I'm new to
all this yeah you can tell hey we got
next Don't make me say it make you say
what there we go that's a boo-boo word
we got next
coach just doesn't feel right
I should be coaching in the NBA well you
never know where things could lead
no doubt
you can get this team to the Special
Olympics finals
you might be ready to be back in the NBA
we've been following your incredible
story coach Marcus is just one win away
from qualifying for the regional
tournament I don't know if you're brave
or crazy
I know this is your shot at being
champions
knocked out
girlfriend problems that was fun you
were passable I don't have a girlfriend
makes sense oh what am I that bad
looking
you know McConaughey